You bring to bear on the world and a priori perceptual structure,
and that's really an embodied structure and it's a consequence of the three and
a half billion years that you've spent putting your body together,
which is a tremendous amount of time and not only your body but your mind of
course,
because your mind is part of your body and very much embedded within it.
You know you,
you tend to think that you have your brain in your head and it's sort of
floating separate from the rest of your body,
but it's not really true.
Your tremendous massive system of neurons running through your entire body,
autonomic neurons in the autonomic nervous system.
Then there on the central nervous system.
So that's a lot of neurons.
And then your central nervous system of course enables you to exercise voluntary
control over your musculature and also to receive information from it.
Your brain is really distributed through your body.
One of the things you may not know is that people who are paraplegic can walk.
If you,
if you suspend them above a treadmill,
their legs will walk by themselves with no voluntary control.
So your spine is capable of quite complex activity.
In fact,
when you walk,
mostly it's a controlled fall and mostly your spine is doing it and so,
so anyways,
the point of all that is that you don't have a blank slate consciousness that's
interpreting a world that manifests itself as segregated objects in some
straight forward.
Since you have a built in interpretive system that's extraordinarily deeply
embedded and invisible because you might think about it as the implicit
structure of your unconscious.
It's what it's what gives rise to your conscious experience and and it presents
you with the world.
That's one way of thinking about it and it's a good way of thinking about it.
It's the psychoanalytic way of thinking about it as well as the neuroscientific
way of thinking about it because one of the things that's pretty interesting
about modern neuroscientist,
especially at the top rate ones,
and those are usually the ones that are working on emotions as far as I've been
able to tell are are often quite enamored of the psychoanalysts.
Jaak Panksepp was a good example of that because they came to understand that
the psychoanalysts insistence on underlying unconscious personified motivations
was actually an accurate reflection of how the brain worked.
And sort of think of yourself as a loose collection of autonomous spirits.
It's governed by some overarching identity is,
is,
is a reasonable way of thinking about it.